the latest in Johnny Depp's court battle
which continues to bring his past drama
with ex Amber Heard back in the
spotlight that's depth today pausing
outside court to lower his bandana mask
and pose for photographers ex-wife Amber
Heard arrived wearing a green bandana
inside it was revealed that Depp's
ex-girlfriend when owned a rider is
expected to testify on his behalf
via videolink next week the actor is
suing a UK tabloid accusing it of
falsely calling him a wife-beater but
his legal strategy yeah that maybe
backfire
so certainly Johnny Depp was trying to
take some kind of stand against the
newspaper however what's happening here
is basically a cyclone it is collapsing
in front of his face that cyclone
includes these photos shown as evidence
Depp apparently passed out on the floor
this image claiming to show Johnny's
whiskey drugs and a custom-made skull
and crossbones pillbox and Depp on a
stretcher with a severed finger he says
it's from amber throwing a baka bottle
she says Depp did it to himself in a
jealous rage Depp also denied claims he
hit amber when she laughed at one of his
tattoos dangled her dog out a car window
and threatened to put the animal in a
microwave and there's more the papers
lawyer read an email Amber allegedly
wrote but never sent to Johnny saying he
was quote like dr. Jekyll and mr. Hyde
half of you I love madly the other half
scares me
amber isn't on trial but the actress and
model has been in court every day and
the newspaper is counting on her
allegations to help their defense she
and Johnny have been locked in a nasty
he-said she-said ever since they
divorced in 2017 she's expected to
testify a week from today and her
testimony will likely include the abuse
claims she made during the deposition
for their divorce one time Johnny was
me and he was hitting me hard and
repeatedly and I was screaming amber how
are you feeling after amber settled her
domestic abuse case with death they
released a joint statement saying quote
there was never any intent of physical
or emotional harm it's possible that we
may also hear some new details emerging
as we've already seen that happen over
the last couple of days with the start
of the trial
[Music]